vous m'avez mis un mot à mon poignet
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un tensiomètre
numérique
donc voilà on va calculer donc déjà vous
appuyez sur start
d'accord on va voilà je vais prendre
votre attention
oui tout à fait normal que ça arrive
jusqu'au 6 mai voilà d'accord ça vibre
au plus bas c'est normal c'est pour
l'instant c'est normal vous regardez
simplement s'il est toujours à lui et
voilà il a lui mis tout à fait d'accord
monsieur excusez moi ça existe plus du
coup les détecteurs de mensonge avait
les deux les deux maintenant ça
maintenant taylor dont il va me dire si
je mens ou pas donc vous allez me poser
des questions ok devant les
téléspectateurs de ces huit en direct et
je vous réponde la vérité enfin c'est un
poteau un mythe 5 plaisir à description
attention c'est des questions évidemment
gênante pour te mettre en galère a bien
sûr j'en attendais pas moins quotas
c'est beau l'amitié
ça commence toujours à imaginer en syrie
d'accord il imagine en syrie on est à la
maison je t'invite et après nous
tranquilles
shalev ma meuf bien sûr brasse
évidemment c'est une bombe atomique nous
attendait pas moins de tapage
j'adore pour cette ligne comme le truc
je m'absente tu vois je vais faire un
petit frigo et tout est ma meuf elle
commence à toucher cyril tranquillement
est ce que je leur en ai dit qu'on
parlait pas d'histoires vécues
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors que tu te dis ça au liban tu vois
où est ce que tu es toi potasse et ça se
fait pas entre photos la clé sur la
libye mais tu es vraiment un ami
attention c'est une bonne masse est
forcément non mais même bombe atomique
ou pas un ami jamais de la vie oui c'est
non et je ne m'en passer non parce que
justement il faut dire vraiment l'aider
réponse claire c'est non non je ne ferai
rien d'accord ce qui dit le contraire
il a peur
sans commentaire cette machine marche
il faut savoir que c'est fiable à 97,9 %
et donc là tu manques il en a les voilà
c'est pas de chance mais c'est des fois
est ce que tu crois du fait du bruit va
voir des textos va voir l'after de ce
truc est ce que tu touches très mince
j'ai tout non mais il me dit oui
l'ars a dit je ne toucherai jamais la
meuf de big flo ou des six machines est
plus importante
on arrête tout on est comme ça sinon
c'est important on sent le docu netflix
nation c'est un gros flop
on part un peu en pensant revient à la
quatrième album c'est un gros flop ça
marche plus du tout est ce que tu
appelles encore est ce que tu es encore
la famille est ce que tu vas encore
rester avec nous ou quoi ai-je bien oui
ou un non
mais c'est non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les mecs bien sûr que franchement ça me
peine que vous me posez cette question
parce que j'étais là vous avez déjà été
votre pote déjà quand je vous disais moi
qui vous appelez au début oui c'est vrai
dit non pour moi non alors je dis je
vous appellerai bien sûr toujours oui je
vous appellerai toujours vous serez
toujours mes potes ça n'est pas pour sa
mère
côté repas plus de ça c'est un ami voilà
et puissant imaginons si un jour je
viens de te voir
je te dit c'est moi j'ai j'ai dit oui à
moitié
mais je te le dit entre nous enfin me
dit tu as l'air tu connais je sais très
bien moi j'ai toujours eu trois quick
est ce que tu vas dire hey frérot ça
c'est entre nous est-ce que tu vas faire
est-ce que tu gardes le secret je ne
vais pas du tout vers ça mais très juste
un message sur un stade main énorme
révélation
[Applaudissements]
j'ai marqué je vais tenir
c'est sûr que je t'appellerai triple
couilles dans la rue c'est que vous
allez me dire il y avait celle que je
voulais régler ton problème avec son
histoire we have allaient alors danser
des répondants fait une dernière j'ai
c'est parce qu'ils savent pas cyril
s'est fait passer pour moi auprès de
kelly hu est bonne en quoi c'était quoi
kelly des semaines des mois et des mois
en fait il avait un autre numéro et je
disais ouais c by chloé faisaient que la
drague et de manière loulou j'aurais pu
avoir des gros soucis
levis c'est que moi je vais raconter me
dit ah ouais ah ouais j'avoue c'est
abusé tout ce que tu fous là question
c'est est ce que il ya eu d'autres
filles à qui tu as fait ça comme kelly
en faisant passer trois noms pour toi
non
[Applaudissements]
franchement est ce que tu as fait que
pour kelly non mais entre noirs et oui
tu fais pas un effrayant oui oui je vais
te dire c'est vrai j'ai fait pour
quelqu'un d'autre me voir un peu plus
qu' il appartient aux états unis à la
dernière question
ça me rassurerait tout ça c'est vraiment
je suis avec toi fourni comme sur
différents mois série d une dernière
question
imaginons des t-shirts seront dispo
imagine en syrie je fais mon
anniversaire
il ya mon père qui chante on est à
toulouse je te demande de venir et c'est
le seul truc c'est qu'il ya un autre
animateur télé mais très connue alors à
la même table syndicales sont notamment
qu'une chose et oui la même date que toi
ah oui qui sait qu'ici que je commence
par a oui oui ça fait dix parties que ça
finit par partir il est à la même table
en cas de refus de jean luc reichmann
écrivent que 10 ne suis pas important
pour nous et à toute la famille à flot
célèbre tout est la question est la
suivante est ce que tu viens
oui ou non alors je vous pouvez mesurer
dans oui je viens je pense que lui ne
donnera pas la seule question il ya deux
choses avec moi il ya trois choses avec
lesquelles on rigole pas l'oseille les
noms
les amis la famille et arthur quoi jouer
merci monsieur blanchet ainsi beaucoup
avait été formidable et au travail ou
parce que social